okay
[Music]
I want to fly ah let's do this
you gotta force it to come out what do
you you're a genius I know like what'd I
say
[Music]
oh did you know what was gonna happen to
my brother when you stuck him with this
world destroying thing
it's called the Scarab
I had no idea it would activate it has
to choose you
so how do we get into unchoose me
acquired who said that systems
[Music]
foreign
the world is a place to protect I have
an Arsenal at my disposal anything
please
whatever you can imagine
I can create yeah that's more like it
hello you feel for your family makes you
weak you're wrong my family that's what
makes me strong
oh I forgot how bad it looks foreign
damn
mother now